[Music]
[Applause]
oh look who just got married Mark
Sanchez Fox NFL analyst yeah
congratulations I had the over all right
Mark Sanchez is married
all right did you cry
yeah okay like a baby real baby she
actually here's why because she woke up
early today to help set me up you can
ask the people backstage getting this
whole thing set up but we're uh we're on
a little vacation here before the season
kicks off and before my son's school
starts so
um you know we make a good team I think
okay but when she walks down got a lot
of work to do you know it's a tough
conference tough division got a lot of
good couples out there we gotta be in it
at the end Crescendo at the right time I
like all that yeah yeah uh when do you
start crying at your wedding
uh so we wrote Our Own vows and um
I knew I was going to tear up uh when
the lights come on when it's game time
because the couple of times I'm writing
you know you get a little choked up and
you're just like ah
that's ridiculous you know come on like
tighten up big guy you know a lot like
fritzy maybe you know like back in my
day
um and so I you know I hit the you know
real men don't cry kind of thing and
then whatever you wrestle with that for
a little bit and then
um
lights came on and it was Game Time and
sure enough the Waterworks came on too
you threw an interception you threw a
pick six right away right away uh I
wouldn't go that far all right let me uh
let me start with college football a
little bit you of course USC alumni uh
what is how did this happen how did all
of this did it happen and is there any
bigger picture solution in your opinion
well I think this whole realignment or
nil or both or they're kind of
you know responsible for each other in
different ways I think in maybe 10 years
when there's like some legit guard rails
on everything and we kind of look back
and say oh yeah okay well that probably
made sense there and oh here's the real
straw that broke the camel's back but I
think one of them had to be this chasing
a national TV or national media model
right because way back in the day right
in black and white with fritzy it was
like get your Regional guys you know and
go fight you know play against the other
guys that are in their region and see
who's better right oh wow UFC Notre Dame
we got a we got a railway that will take
these teams together and unite the
country well those were like the
beginnings of what we're seeing today
and with the Pac-12 and the lack of a
national media model
FC's like you know we gotta go boys we
gotta we gotta get out of here we gotta
chase this stuff if we're gonna be on TV
and be relevant and show these kids in
Florida Texas and all on the East Coast
everywhere else that hey football is Big
here because it's not like when Matt
leinert and Reggie Bush were playing
that everybody in the on the Eastern
Seaboard would tune into that 11 o'clock
game uh you know on on uh in L.A so now
without that without that vehicle to
basically promote yourself and help a
recruit they got to go to something
bigger and the Big Ten was the answer
when it comes to nil
I mean it's the Wild Wild West right now
I think at some point there'll be some
guard rails and rules but who's I you
know I find it hard I wouldn't want to
be the person in the position to blow
the whistle first on somebody for
breaking a rule right especially right
now especially with the way the NCAA
kind of looks publicly like their Public
Image isn't beautiful and shiny and
sweet it's a little like hey man you
guys been holding these players down for
a long time and now they're getting paid
you guys kind of blew that and what's
going on with conferences is there
really an NCAA you know there's a lot of
questions about that so would you have
said that I am at USC with Anna if if
you were getting paid you know it's
interesting because I've I've thought
about this quite a bit in the last year
and it's not to stay
it's hard to say now in in retrospect
looking back saying like well if they
would offered me 10 million dollars
maybe I don't go
um
I don't I mean are you staying for the
money I don't know is the money a new
thing you know is it in that last year
that they say hey here's 10 million
bucks you stay it's yours it's all legal
and above board shoot that would have
made me think about it at least one more
time I can't guarantee I wouldn't have
made the same decision but
um you know it was part of that was if
I'm staying the the
chances of getting hurt you know the
chances of this new CBA coming down the
chances whatever like it was just the
right time for me personally in that
moment but you know I've heard stories
about CJ Stroud and these guys that you
know different programs where it's like
he was gonna leave he he obviously left
but he was gonna leave and they put
together a pretty nice package for him
to say how much did you hear you know uh
I don't know I've heard different
numbers I've heard anywhere from 10 to
20 and I was just like whoa because if
it's that high
then we're talking something serious
right like what's he gonna get paid on
his rookie deal 25 28 29 I don't know
what the you know first year is but it's
slotted now and then to go back compete
for a Heisman compete for a national
championship potentially have those two
things in your pocket plus let's just
call it 15 million dollars
I mean I know I don't know it's that's
not too bad you know if you were even
in any way hesitant about going to the
next level uh skill wise maturity wise
you know physically emotionally anything
like that shoot you know if I'm his
parents I'm like well I know a safe
option you know what I mean that's true
so uh we're talking to Mark Sanchez uh
Fox NFL analyst trying to figure out if
you're the Texans and you got CJ Stroud
or Bryce young how much do you play in
the preseason if you know they are going
to be your starter week one sure well I
think okay the old school model
that I was a part of and I can speak to
was you know the first game there used
to be four preseason games number one
now there's three but uh the first game
you get about a quarter
ish a series maybe two right a total of
anywhere from 8 to 15 kind of plays
basically because you can't guarantee
with the way the game plays out
second uh second
game you're playing at least two to
three drives you know right around uh
middle of the second quarter whatever
depends if you go out and blow it out of
the water have two scoring drives boom
get his ass out of there and keep him
healthy and upright throw in some
sandals give them some sunflower seeds
and let them watch the rest
third game is like your dress rehearsal
you'll go through the first half get
into the third quarter at least one
drive in the third quarter and then
after that you kind of shut it down the
fourth game was to round out the bottom
of your roster and then you know you go
play in about I think it's like 10 days
after that fourth game now with just the
three
uh chances in preseason that third game
has become the game to kind of round out
the roster now guys play about a quarter
maybe uh two quarters in the first and
second game and the idea is just to get
them live reps at situations you want
them having to handle third Downs you
want them to have uh handle you know
first and second Downs that you can rep
you know in practice anyway but you want
them to do a two-minute drill you want
them to do you want them to have a third
long a third and short a Red Zone
opportunity you just want to simulate
those as best you can keep them upright
while while maintaining his health for
the season and then let him go play now
with the introduction of all these joint
practices or maybe the growing
popularity of these joint practices you
can get a lot of those reps in those
scenarios because you can script it a
certain way and that defense is trying
to tee off now the chances of you
getting just completely blown up in a
joint practice as a quarterback are much
much lower than a real preseason game
because in a real preseason game you're
wearing the same color jersey in the
joint practice they're told still not to
get near the quarterback but inevitably
there's a guy who's trying to make the
roster and trying to make a name for
himself and you know he might beat
somebody around the edge and he's coming
for you so he's going to give you a
little contact but
bottom line is you're balancing those
two things and I don't know how any of
the GMS or coaches have any fingernails
left after preseason because these guys
are watching you know their new shiny
toy at Christmas and it's that remote
control car and there goes the neighbor
just playing with it and you're like oh
God oh God you know so you're scared
that that something's gonna happen I saw
this video of Trayvon Diggs picking off
Dak Prescott a couple of times and then
talking trash to him
and I'm wondering how often does that
happen if you threw an interception in
practice
would the defense like really you know
Trayvon Diggs was not holding back I
mean he was calling out Dak Prince
I've seen I've seen the clip I think you
know those kind of things
um
in that moment I mean you never know
what went into it and it's kind of funny
because after those things happen at
practice
you're already like you're already fine
with that your relationship with that
player has already
been mended even if it were ever
broken or frayed I guess and then you
got to go talk to the media about it and
then they kind of remind you about it so
I wouldn't think it's not like you know
he said that to Dak and Dak was just
like failed between his legs like a sad
puppy and walking in a locker room like
man I got no friends I don't think
that's the case at all I think it's just
incredibly competitive
and that kind of tense environment and
that's what you want now you know people
are going to have their take on it
because it was cut out of context and
then pasted everywhere for everyone to
see but I don't see a problem with it
and it also depends on the players like
their relationship I mean Bart Scott
used to rip my head off all the time I
could barely get my first couple snap
counts off because he's screaming at me
yelling at me you know you uh Richie
Valens looking La Bamba love it you know
what this and that uh Hey nacho nacho
hey what's the snap count nacho you know
he's screaming at me and
um
Rex didn't want to stop that
no come on it was great it was it's
it's what your rookie quarterback goes
through and those are like okay The
Growing Pains but then like you know a
guy like that like Bart
dude's got your back like if anybody
cheap shot at me or something like
that's the dude who would Sprint on the
field uh same thing with Mangold same
thing with those like they just have
your back and it's like you know
this is a part of your Growing Pains
young guy but you're one of us you know
they got your their arm around you at
the same time a little different between
Dak and Trayvon because they're you know
similar age or Dax a little older
whatever so uh but but that's the way
it's supposed to be you're supposed to
cultivate this environment that's so
competitive that pushes you to the edge
right when it's about to break out into
a fight and then you literally just walk
away or stand still and let them get the
penalty you know I mean that was like an
old P Carroll thing we push it to the
brink like right to the edge of the
cliff and let them jump off we don't
jump off we don't lose our cool where do
you stand on this Eric the enemy
Commander's story where the enemy I
guess is being rough on the players he
says he's intense he's old school and
they went to Ron Rivera to complain
about Eric the enemy yelling at them
what are you going to get from Ron I
mean Ron's a tough old school Dude too
yeah I mean you know the new athlete is
not used to being yelled at
I mean but yeah sure but I think it's
like who are you
who who's gonna come to save the day the
guy who played linebacker in the league
you know three cbas ago come on now I
don't know that's
the right uh but Rivera talked about it
that's the problem he told the media
about it instead of keeping that
in-house where yeah I feel like it was
so I didn't see the interview I I had
heard Rumblings of this and
I mean there's so many media Outlets
searching for something right now timing
is everything timing is everything so I
don't know necessarily what would make
coach want to say that
um but maybe it's like uh you know like
hey we brought maybe his intention was
like we brought the right guy in he's
ruffled some feathers around here and
that's what we want once again Trayvon
Diggs and board uh and and Dak Prescott
Bart Scott and me as a young rookie it's
like get this stuff as tough as you can
and simulate every tough situation you
possibly can because I guarantee we're
gonna get him if these are the toughest
situations we get all season boys we're
we're a gravy like we are good and
that's that's the idea of training camp
simulate the toughest hardest stuff just
like military training and then when it
happens in the in the season boom I've
done it I've been there I know what to
do a lot like you know fritzy somebody
had to tell him to get his freaking
hands out of his pocket in the sound
check so we can go up there and have the
stage presence we know he has I thought
I would have seen a little Shirelles
like a little hand boom something you
know a little something but my man was
just like
you know Flat Stanley up there Frenchie
was sort of our Napoleon Dynamite when
he gets up on stage where he's not even
really engaging with the audience hands
in his pockets and uh
but he got through it I mean he did he
did he stood there I'm proud of him
stood there like a champion stood there
like a champion uh well congrats on the
nuptials as we like to say just just
take it one anniversary at a time okay
yeah one anniversary at a time all right
yeah uh thank you bud good to talk to
you again
appreciate you guys Mark Sanchez Fox NFL
analyst former NFL USC quarterback